de cáncer immune response can be
conceptualized as a series of stepwise
events referred to as the cancer
immunity cycle the cycle include step
one release of cancer cell antigens step
two cancer antigen presentation step 3
priming at activation step four
trafficking of immune cells to tumors
step 5
infiltration of immune cells into tumors
step 6
recognition of cancer cells by t-cells
and step 7 killing of cancer cells in
this exercise we will profile the status
of anti-cancer immunity across seven
step of cancer immunity cycle and infer
the proportion of various tumor
infiltrating immune cells using the
tracking tumor immune of phenotype or t
IP web-based tool the T IP is a meta
server which integrates systematically
to existing third party methods for
tracking to start with the immuno type
profiling we will first need to clean up
the transcriptomics data set note for
the data set to be uploaded to the t IP
there should be no missing values within
the table and no duplication of gene ID
to prepare the data set we will first
remove the unnamed gene ID
next we will remove the columns with
zero read count
and finally we will remove any
duplicated gene ID
once the data set is cleaned up we will
save it as a separate TSV file
now we will upload the file onto the TI
P tool
once the analysis is done you can export
the results for further analysis
you